bill how you doing my name is Marty
bessman I'm from Boston Massachusetts
New England my question for you is do
you believe that is a space expanse it
starts moving at a faster and less can
less controlled rate I've always wanted
this given our ancestors had such a
closer view of time and space than we
have now and it seems to have moving
pretty much faster away from us then as
they had such a huge view of the
galaxies and what they've written and
map down thank you very much
Marty Marty Marty so you're asking a
great question keep in mind that in my
grandfather's time it was believed by a
great many people that the universe was
static that it just is the way it's
always been it's this it's big some
extraordinarily huge size and it had it
had always been that way then in my
father's time relativity was discovered
and furthermore the expanding universe
was discovered this discovered nominally
or largely credited to Edwin Hubble and
that's why we named the Space Telescope
after Hubble because he was looking at
the Stars
he was an astronomer studying various
types of stars and he could identify
different types of stars and then
realized that all of them of a certain
type were moving farther away fast at a
very high speed and he determined this
through this famous expression the
redshift he noticed that the stars were
slightly redder than he would have
expected and this he attributed to their
speed stretching the wavelengths of
light out it's amazing and this was
around 1927 nine 28:29 Hubble realized
the universe was expanding and this was
consistent with certain aspects of
relativity of Einstein postulated
postulations or theories all right well
then in your lifetime Artie people
discovered that the universe is not only
expand in fact
Hubble made the discovery everybody
presumed or questioned or tried to
figure out at what rate the universe
would slow down in other words everybody
figured there's gravity there's a big if
everything's expanding expanded from a
place and keep in mind the big insight
is not just that the matter that you and
I are made of in the Sun is made of
expanded that space itself is expanding
it's a hard idea if you're not troubled
by this idea you're I don't know you're
odd but that space itself is expanding
and furthermore it was presumed that it
would slow down that their gravity would
make things slowed down in their
expansion and people are trying to
figure out that rate but what they
discovered around the year 2000 Nobel
Prize I think was awarded in 2004 what
they discover is universe is
accelerating and you know why it's
accelerating nobody knows why Marty and
this is the fascination this is a source
it just makes us all crazy in a good way
and so in this mix now it's been
discovered that there is about five
times as much matter or whatever it is
that we can't see which is come to be
called dark matter and it's about five
times as much of that as there is of the
stuff that you and I are made of and you
know why nobody knows why but its
gravitational influences of great
significance when you start to study the
cosmos so you Marty are living at a time
where the next great discovery about the
expansion of the universe the nature of
space and time is understood you may be
here when the next amazing
world-changing insight in astrophysics
or physics or science is made so when
you go to vote Marty vote to support
basic research because these discoveries
are important to us that's why it's how
we have nuclear power plants it's how we
have the internet is understanding this
physics
of subatomic particles and how they
relate to the physics of the cosmos our
place in space and so who knows what the
next great discovery will lead to but
it's worth pursuing because we all want
to know where we came from we want to
know where we fit in the cosmos our
place in space cool question
carry on